Bonjour, c'est Cyprien !
Vous allez bien ?
Moi ? Ca va pas trop.
J'ai fait mon premier bide, hein.
Mais un bon bide quoi.
Imaginons, ça c'est un bide normal...
Là, j'ai fait...
Voilà. Un truc comme ça à peu près.
Pour s'en rendre compte, il suffit de regarder le nombre d'avis négatifs sur YouTube.
Alors, au début j'étais...
Aaaaaah, mais qu'est-ce que j'ai fait !
Bon, et après quelques instants de réflexion...
Respire... Pfiou, voilà...
En gros la vidéo, c'est sur un mec qui s'habille mal...
... et à la fin il s'habille tellement mal, qu'il s'habille bien.
C'est pas super clair en plus, j'avoue bon...
La vidéo s'appelle Comme une merde...
Comme une merde... le titre lui va bien alors !
Bon, pour synthétiser l'avis général, s'il fallait matérialiser cette vidéo...
... ce serait un caca. Voilà.
Faut que j'me lave les mains maintenant...
Y'a plein de raisons d'expliquer ce fait : d'un, l'humour
était trop éloigné de c'que j'fais d'habitude, hein.
C'était trop méchant, le sujet était mal traité.
Et puis je commence à comprendre que les musiques, c'est pas trop mon truc...
Hein, la prochaine fois que j'fais une chanson, c'est simple.
Hé, j'ai une idée de chanson !
Pétez-moi les genoux.
Merci, mec !
D'ailleurs, la vidéo est toujours en ligne, elle
n'est juste plus répertoriée sur ma chaîne.
Parce que c'est devenu un petit peu un lieu de violence et d'insultes.
Hein, euh... Un petit peu comme dans le film 300 en fait.
A peu de choses près, c'est...
Donc si vous aimez vous faire du mal, vous pouvez toujours voir
la vidéo, le lien est dans la description sur YouTube.
D'ailleurs vous pouvez y mettre un pouce rouge hein, parce que c'est
dommage, y'a encore un p'tit peu d'vert dans la barre.
Alors je sais qu'y a un forum et la communauté qui va avec
qui s'amuse à amplifier cette vague d'avis négatifs et de commentaires insultants.
C'est de la merde, connard, va te pendre.
Cool !
Je n'ai absolument rien contre ça, hein, les gens peuvent noter et commenter ce qu'ils
veulent. D'ailleurs, si ma vidéo était réussie j'n'aurais pas eu tous ces commentaires, bref...
J'me suis planté.
Tu t'es planté... comme une merde !
Maintenant, j'ai retenu la leçon, je vais bosser sur d'autres
vidéos en espérant qu'elles ne décevront plus personne.
Adieu.